Well you demanded it so here, it is my newest cosplay video. I present to you moon night
Jazz kidding last people care about that guy than Deadpool in 2008
Will make you extremely mainstream and overexposed to the mass media one day Spectre
one day
For now though even though. I struggle like hell not to be a spider-man Channel
You just keep pulling me back in so let's get down to it
You all want to know about a man named Riley Ben Riley is the less well-off clone of spider-man that made everyone very angry in
The 90s for being a dumb concept he lived in squalor and made a costume for himself with like $50
So I've affectionately named this one grunge rock hobo spider-man
For those who suffered through my last two cosplay tutorials
You know the drill by now get our usual supplies ready
Red morphsuit separate masks fabric glue that stuff you put on the edges of cloth after cutting it
So it doesn't fray like crazy and probably some alcohol to ease the troubled soul of your emotionally distraught mother who has to constantly help
You with these god-awful cosplay projects at the expense of her free time and sanity
Usual supplies so for the red suit you just oh
Well jeez that's pretty easy then you don't have to do anything this design is so simple just put it on and it's ready
Well, that's a lot of steps removed from that other crap good thing. I didn't pick Kayne Souter
I'd have to color the entire head and shoulders and black paint while wearing it so the next
Step is to take a blue hoodie provided by your uncle on a scenario in which he was like hey
Here's a bunch of clothes that don't fit me anymore. I brought them in several large trash bags
So you could maybe use some of it for a cosplay or something?
and
Then you respond accordingly with but drew I can you only use maybe two articles of clothing in here for something the rest are just
Taking up a ton of space and you clearly found it easier to just dump all this on me instead of driving a few extra
minutes to the local goodwill you lazy Punk
And it'll be like yeah basically make sure you say all of that to the very letter if either you or your uncle
Mispronounce a word the costume won't work anyway at least I got the blue hoodie
but as it turns out there's a bit of a
Scaling difference between my uncle and I do to my faulty Irish genetics that spilled into my bloodline at some point in the last few
Centuries of heritage as such I got to modify this hoodie a bit to get it to look right first
I cut it in half so could have that grungy 90s Bill and Ted crop top look
Because skater culture and heavy metal became big motifs when Todd and Rob took the industry by storm an indirectly almost bankrupted Marvel TV
Allure to the max bro tell you pin parts of the hoodie together to make it fit a little smaller
Sew it together with the trusty sewing machine you probably stole and then cut the excess fabric out near the seams that you've created
Now of course a lot of clothes have these darn brand logos on them, so you'll know which middle-eastern sweatshop
Put it together 20 years later this one
Isn't a decal or printed on or something easy this thing is intricately woven into the fabric and requires a ton of effort to remove
Thus you get a thing called a stitch Ripper and stip some riches?
I can't remember if I'm recalling the process I did or instructing you to do these things anymore so the language
Changes every other sentence even though no one will care or notice except me
Hey for all of you whiny technology age kids that got offended by my use of a camera from 2009
I used all of my graduation money to buy a 4k camera, so you'd stop telling me
I recorded all of these on a potato I could have used that money to buy food
But I used it to please you resolution obsessed basket cases the video compression on YouTube sucks anyway
So you can't even tell us 4k so like who cares about anything life is meaningless now
You can't apply the spider logo with a marker by free-handing it
But I wanted to be a little more thorough and make sure it was just right
I printed one out from Google Image Search and cut it out of a piece of flimsy cardboard with an x-acto knife
Step 11 once you've created a stencil for your logo and completely inappropriate conditions come to the realization that you've made a giant mistake
Step 14
stir the red velvet mix in a bowl until it's finally nice and viscous place the mix into separate sections of a cupcake sheet and
bake at 450 degrees
Once you've stayed up until 5 a.m.
On a school night making apology cupcakes for your mother after carving a giant spider logo into her expensive kitchen table
you're ready to paint the hoodie I
Found this nice black fabric paint at that store for old ladies that I always look weird hanging out in whoa demonetised
Sorry everyone. I didn't know this paint brand was abbrasive expect a half-hearted apology video in two to three business days
So I kept the stencil firmly in place on the hoodie and used a paintbrush to apply it
Nor more of that spray paint stuff. I'm done with that noise
Thankfully the hoodie was thick enough that the paint didn't bleed through it also dried rather quickly this stuff's great, and now you're done
Oh, yeah, uh siree, so he can sell more toys. Got it making Ben Riley's web-shooters can go a number of ways
I took some elastic and a belt from Walmart to do the next step
I used some silver puff paint to coat the elastic after cutting it to fit snugly around my wrist
the paint makes it pretty rigid
But it'll still stretch attach them together both ends with the sewing machine
The web cartridge is I bought a huge pack of Nerf darts and spray-painted them
Most people will tell you to wear protective gear over your mouth and eyes during spray painting
But I can't afford any of that stuff
So I just try not to inhale too much paint
Sometimes the air coming out of the can pushes the darts too hard
and they roll away because they're made of super light foam it's very annoying I
Used this straw from a soda from Arby's to prod the darts around and rotate them without touching the paint with my hands
Which gave me the idea to make it the nozzle on the web-shooter
There's like a red dot thingy on the belt buckle so I made a stencil the size of a quarter
Painted on there I tried to use fabric paint on metal at first like a complete idiot
And then it bled through the masking tape ah god damn it then I meticulously scrubbed all the paint off to try it again
White has been Riley have a red button on his belt buckle you may ask no reason
That's just the way they drew them sometimes
It's not even there
All right, hot glue the web cartridges on the belt in the elastic don't burn yourself not that you listen to anything I say
Okay, now for the big important part the mask from what I can tell right lobe ends mask always has way bigger lenses than his
Counterpart I took my friend Andres advice in order to pair these pre-made ones to use for a Miles Morales suit
Let's pick up our trusty
Spandex rag and get ready to mangle it in the name of cosplay these new lenses are made of like
Plastic and plywood or something so don't drill any holes in them just be very thorough about gluing them
Well the mask is kind of shaped weird now because these lenses stretch it in such an odd way
Now the outline of my mouth is super easy to see just like Jenn Miley's other terrible costume that he got rid of
Immediately because it sucked so bad
I also think I kind of screwed up with the mask because there's no space between my eyes and the lenses so it's like
Hard to blink. It's touching my eyeball
Huh note to self stick with what you know never experiment, not gonna lie. I don't really recommend these lenses
I'm not happy enough with the look to justify the difficulty of working with them
But if you can figure out a way to make it look good
Then give it a try well that was much like the character itself
Underwhelming, let's spice this one up a little and do another one this costume video is going into overtime
Since the theme of today is people that have no discernible differences from Peter Parker in any way
Here's an unrelated picture of Miles Morales. Oh, I'm just kidding
He's alright actually like his costume more than Peter Parker's because the red and black color scheme
So let's give that a shot but Xavier
You can't cosplay a character who doesn't have the same skin color as you even though no skin is visible in the cosplay
that's
ray cess
Oh, I'm sorry small child turns out you're not allowed to like or enjoy things that look different from you this character wasn't made for
You you're going to have to wear the politically correct spider-man costume excuse me sir
But that costume is for a character that looks different
I'm afraid
I'm going to have to ask you to change you know I I hate this awful world for making me get political
But one of you Schmucks was gonna bring it up if I didn't address it yeah anyway
While I did most of the heavy lifting on the last one this suit will have to rely heavily on the help of my tired
And disenfranchised assistant from homes loins my curse it exists spawned
since I don't have a mannequin let alone one in my size all the
Painting work will have to be while I'm wearing the damn thing again so for the big red stripes
Masking tape and fabric paint will do you fine?
Thankfully it's not as complex a pattern is that other nightmare
So the lines on this one are really straight, and the paint is kind of glossy
If you were making a spider-man homecoming cosplay I'd recommend using this method for all those extraneous black lines
After that just kind of wing it on the webs
They're kind of hard to screw up
Plus with the paint being applied like frosting to a cake and has this 3d effect to it
That looks better than just drawing it with markers of course I recommend doing the rough draft of them with like a sharpie or something
First then you can just kind of print out the logo
Trace the outline of it and go nuts the paint is of course going to be on you for like three weeks
But the results are pretty cool
I watched Point Break with David for an episode of his show couch potatoes while doing the webs on the back
you might see that video at some point in the next three years the
Mask should be easy we made a ton of these by now in other videos for more on that go check these out
I had a friend paint them red for me with probably spray paint or whatever. I didn't really ask questions
I just sort of rolled up to his house in the middle of the night you ran them out to me on the street like
It was some kind of shrug deal, so I don't really know what he did to them
Oh, yeah, put some masking tape over the shiny part first
So now you got a mask with red outlines on the thing thankfully a foam mannequin
Head is actually pretty easy to find so no red grid on my face today. Just do it
How you did the body silver lines first red lines second should go okay?
Be sure to use an action figure as a reference so you know how the pattern is meant to fit over a 3-dimensional object
Some artists have a tendency to cut corners, or draw it in a way
That's not honest to how it would really look so you can't trust every picture you get on google image search
So the logo on the back I wanted to try something a little different
We painted the pattern out on a piece of parchment paper
That was partially translucent
Then let it dry overnight the thing peeled off surprisingly easily and was totally intact at the end
The paint was even strong enough that you could tug on it and stretch it a little in the logo wouldn't you tear so we?
Glued that onto the back with rubber cement which actually burns like crazy
So just use fabric glue the fingers were pretty easy just paint them with a spongy brush
I have really long fingers, though
So I had to wear it to tape off the parts correctly because the fabric needs to stretch the right way so then uh
Yeah, I guess that's it all right
I enjoy going as miles for conventions
Just remember not to take the mask off if your complexion matches mine because you'll probably get some dirty looks
Maybe from now on I should diversify my cosplays a little more for every six spider-man suits. I have like one moon night
How about you fellas in the comments tell me about some non spider-man characters
I could also make cosplays for in the meantime. I got to get me a plate of chicken wings
And what the hell are you doing out here uh?
Duh, I'm Nick Fury director of shield. I'm here to tell you about the Avengers initiative
I don't remember Nick Fury being a member of the Backstreet Boys captain crop-top. Well you know Dawg
I'm just picking up some dank chicken wings Holmes. I got the munchies like a monkey no
I'm saying for sheezy money Z. It ain't easy P and cheese. Hey, don't distract me with my love of Ebonics
Who are you extremely bright person well Xavier? It's time. I told you the truth
You're my clone
Shirley before we started this YouTube channel you and I had a chance encounter that turned into combat during our epic battle we became swapped
Unclear as to which of us was the real Xavier after our first meeting
I assumed I was the clone and left to go live a life on the road eating hugh's
Sandwiches out of dumpsters in the city while you became a z-list internet celebrity any questions
How do you use a sandwich without eating it all so if I'm the one who started YouTube channel aren't I the more like
Successful and interesting one. Why come back and ruin everything?
Oh, well, I actually just show up here every couple of days to steal food from your freezer
Rick
If you continue this conversation you'll disrupt the timestream
Well are you I'm the half Hispanic guy with the black and red costume and a father with a dark secret that takes your place
After you die so miles who howdy
Okay, are you guys serious come on this guy's a total knockout? What's your deal? Oh? You know the usual?
Wealth and fame. I'm ignored action is my reward what you mean like the affirmative kind
Woahh, settle down there Hans Zimmer 2099
Want to be exactly like that guy when I grow up like like 100 percent no deviations and personality at all
I'll make sure that doesn't happen you usurper will them
All only the one true and see here can rule the YouTube channel. I am the one true replacement and/or original